- I don't know why I can't
retain like anything about
like elementary school,
but for some reason I can
remember all the details
about Rugrats. (laughing)
(upbeat music)
We are bringing our childhood
dreams to life today.
We are trying--
- [Together] Reptar Bars!
- This was the favorite candy
of The Rugrats' children.
- It is the candy of
my youth, that I wanted
more than anything else.
- Halt, I am Reptar.
- [Together] Halt, I am Reptar.
Halt, I am Reptar.
- Rugrats?
- Oh.
- It was so good.
- Oh, classic.
- And I still watch
clips on YouTube and cry.
- I was obsessed with Reptar.
I knew all the episodes with it in it.
And I thought he was a real thing!
- (singing) Gotta stinky
diaper your still the
little brother that I prayed for.
I guess you make me love you.
Shit, man.
- I don't know it was a, it
was a very sentimental moment.
Now what, do you--
- I'm okay.
I'm okay.
- Bring on the chocolate bars.
- Yes.
- Wow, aw shit.
- It's real.
- Wow!
Does it really turn your tongue green?
It says it does!
- It says it turns your tongue green.
- It has instructions.
Tear open.
- Step two: chomp.
- And step three is roar
like Reptar (laughing).
- [Together] Ahh!
- Oh wow!
- Oh my God!
- [Woman 1] She's beautiful.
- Look at this.
- [Woman 1] Uh!
- Oh!
- It is good.
- Mm hmm.
- It's really good.
- I was expecting it to be
sweet, but that is somehow
sweeter than what candy already is.
- Need a moment?
- Mmm
- Oh, look at that squish out.
- Mmm hmm.
I was expecting a little bit more, like,
detailing on the chocolate.
In the cartoon the bar was
actually shaped like Reptar.
- The frosting tastes better
than I thought it would.
- Dude.
- I don't like frosting much.
I've always thought it kinda gross.
- I love frosting.
- Uh
- It's a little green.
- I think--
- Not as green as I want it to be.
- It's a real like sewage green.
It's like a very brown hue to it.
- Yeah, yours is mostly
a sewage green too.
Ah I was really hoping the
whole of my tongue would
stick out of my face and
then be like the mask--
- Yeah
- Green.
Like Jim Carrey green.
- Ooh it's getting there
I think you need to like
lick the toxicity.
= [Both] (roaring)
- Tastes like chocolate.
- It tastes like chocolate.
- It's good--
- It's--
- I think I would rather have
it for the novelty of it.
Like I'd rather have the full
one to just put on my shelf
to like impress men that
come and sleep over.
Be like here's my Harry Potter collection,
here's my Reptar Bar.
- Look how cool I am.
- Yeah.
- Nostalgia's so real.
- Like no matter who you are.
We've only met a couple months ago--
- Mmm
- Completely different
childhoods, different parts
of the world, but we love the Rugrats.
- It is stuff like this,
no matter what's going on
in the world, stuff like this
can bring people together.
- Yeah, I'm glad we got to have this.
It's something I definitely
dreamed about wanting
all the time when I was
a kid and even though
eating it now, like, it's just candy.
- This is more about the
idea of like, dreaming about
something as a kid and then
in whatever form that takes
it becomes real.
I feel like there's a
little bit of magic to it.
It's a little magical.
- [Together] Halt, I am Reptar.
Halt, I am Reptar.
- You just do this throughout the trailer.
- Halt, I am Reptar.
- Halt.
- Subscribe cards come over us.
Halt, I am Reptar.
- Halt.
- [Woman 1] And there all
like, are they still out there
halting Reptar?
[Woman 2] Halt, I am Reptar.
(laughing)
(whooshing)
(squeaking swinging sign)